wild card miranda lambert
best country album for wild card this is
miranda lambert's third grammy win ever
which is going to surprise a lot of
people she has rightly
dominated the country music award shows
over the years but the grammys have
never shown her that much love
so back in 2011 she won best country
solo performance for the house to build
me
and then in 2015 she won best country
album for platinum
but yeah in 2016 her incredible album
the weight of these wings
was on everyone's best of lists for the
year
people were even thinking she was gonna
get out of the year nomination
not only did she not get that she didn't
even get a country album
nomination so this feels like a bit of
justice for miranda
thank you to the grammys for putting
this together and letting us at least
kind of be together and say hi
um brandi ingrid and little big town
ashley back in nash we
we are so we're such a family in country
music so i feel like
holding this right now and hold it for
all of us especially us girls
and all the stars
[Music]
while she's already got a new hit with l
king on
drunk i love that song miranda is
already prepping her new album the
stripped down
mark for tapes which will come out in
may and she said backstage i love this
she still loves and focuses on making a
great album
you put your heart soul into the i still
make albums i think everybody in the
category does you know we
still romanticize about having a full
project to represent where we are in
life and
where are creatively so this record
really um
i needed it in my life at the time and
that we made it and i feel like
it's i mean it obviously feels amazing
to celebrate that but
but i loved i love all that people in
the category with me and
like i said we're family so you know i
feel like i'm bringing it home
for all of us